but the pile of feces in the live-action
Pinocchio is the most likable character
what do you love about Disney Live
Action remakes
uh I don't love anything about Disney
Live Action remakes I think these are
the worst films of our time
that represent everything wrong with
Factory filmmaking and Studio Executives
and lawyers deciding they need to make a
movie to somehow preserve the
intellectual property
and the Disney Live Action remakes with
the exception of a few I would say the
Jungle Book by John Favreau but almost
all of them have been
incredibly unwatchable
uh thankfully the classic films on which
they're based still exist you know uh
films like Pinocchio Beauty and the
Beast and whatnot but the live action
remakes have been the worst Pinocchio in
particular was one that had me
specifically angry
because
it was in first of all embarrassing at
how bad the film was
everything wrong you're taking the
design of the original Pinocchio and
rendering it in computer animation and
it's the exact same design you get Tom
Hanks to play Geppetto who
it's interesting you know in the
original animation of Pinocchio it's
you you have Geppetto and he's so
excited to have a young boy a son but
when you take these Concepts and from
animation 2D animation and put them into
live action there's something about it
that is at the very least unsettling of
a live-action Tom Hanks dancing with joy
that he has a young boy
a young live boy
that's his
I don't want to like
I don't know how long of a dramatic
pause I could put there after saying
those words but there's something about
it that just seems weird in live action
and I think that that's something if you
look at um animated shows like The
Simpsons when they talk about religion
or politics uh or just so many different
issues that The Simpsons touch on you
could never do that in live action you
couldn't do a live-action sitcom that
discussed those ideas
I mean you used to be able to with all
in the family but the only way to to
tackle those ideas unfortunately in a
mainstream way is uh is in 2D animation
or at least you used to be able to
but the but the live-action Disney films
are
just a travesty and sort of represent
everything wrong with modern movies
today
everything wrong uh just the you know
updating it for modern audiences uh with
um unnecessary gender and race swaps uh
that I think that audiences are
beginning to Tire of
um the live action doesn't really work
there's certain Concepts and ideas that
work best in animation perhaps that's
why perhaps that's why the Jungle Book
is probably the one that stands out as
it is the most watchable and probably
um the best of them
is because it's it's all animated it's
all animated with the exception of the
young boy but
but my God these these Disney animated
or these Disney Animation translations
to live action are are travesty I feel
like I could teach a class where we just
watch parts of Pinocchio daily and I
tell you why this isn't working
um
you know there's even a scene in which
Pinocchio trips over a pile of feces
covered in flies
and
part of me thinks that the reason that
the feces in Pinocchio with the the
Flies you could hear the Flies is so
graphic it was like the animators put
that in to let us know yeah we know
we know too they are this bad
and that film just
um it just it's it's horrific I I really
get the sense that it's it's um an
attorney is saying look we need to
remake these and we need to brand them
to remind people
it's it's somewhat similar to there was
a trend in the 90s to do sequels to
classic Disney animated films Cinderella
to
Lion King 2
Bambi to
um and you can probably find them at
yard sales
um in the clamshell VHS casing you can
find the sequels to all the classic
Disney animated features and they're all
completely forgettable and I wish they
never existed
and I would say the same for all of
these Disney Live Action films is
literally an attorney saying well
just do it
I I am I it's disappointing to see
people like uh Robert zemeckis
who made you know
a short on a short list of perfect films
Made Back to the Future
right and then to see Tom Hanks
probably the most beloved actor
um
you know you could still call him a star
for them to team up with Disney to make
it is horrific
and I just hope that Disney stops
not to get too graphic but I am curious
with the pile of feces and the Flies uh
what in what context was that in the
scene well Pinocchio is skipping his way
to school he's distracted and happens
upon a pile of feces it's a completely
unnecessary
thing to happen in the midst of the
live-action remake of the classic
Pinocchio to put in this pile of feces
but I do believe that that was a not so
secret message
that the animators may have just decided
to add
um
why would they do this
uh otherwise there's there's no point in
it does it pay off later in the story
is it on his shoe and he says um I I I
don't I don't recall that it that it
pays off or has meaning but the pile of
feces in the live-action Pinocchio is
the most likable character
oh okay great I say I say that with a
straight face
I have some numbers here uh Lion King
1.6 billion dollars worldwide Beauty and
the Beast 1.2 billion
Aladdin over a billion World worldwide
and The Jungle Book almost a billion
so what about the fact that many of
these remakes are huge business you talk
about a lawyer that could be sitting
behind their you know thing their
computer figuring out numbers yeah
doesn't it make sense though
sure it makes Financial sense to remake
classic and familiar intellectual
property into another form from live
action to or from animation to live
action that makes total sense on paper
uh I think these films are completely
creatively bankrupt and forgettable and
it's unfortunate that audiences
um would not be more discriminating when
it comes to these come to these movies
so I I just don't think that we're going
to be talking about any of these
live-action Disney remakes far into the
future will still be discussing the
classic films upon upon which they're
based and now forgive me I'm not a
parent but I know that you know moms
need a break dads need a break is this
the kind of movie that hey guys we're
gonna get in the car and go see a movie
what are we going to see Pinocchio there
there is there is definitely a school of
thought that will that will say that the
reason that these movies are profitable
is they're effectively uh babysitters so
um that could could also be a reason for
the success and also I kind of find it
there's always a movie and this is in
particular around the holidays usually
Thanksgiving or or Christmas and whatnot
there's a movie that
um offends no one is not interesting
completely forgettable but it's the only
movie the entire family can agree that
we can all go see together
so that's why you see movies opening on
Christmas day right that it is a thing a
lot of movies open on Christmas Day
and not everybody wants to go see The
Godfather 3 on Christmas Day
but they'll go see something like
like
a Disney Live Action remake I I despise
these films with every fiber of my being
so I find they uh
you know I mean I guess the best thing
you can say about them is it keeps
certain artists employed